it's not about abandoning goals it's
contextualizing the goals and what most
businesses lack is context for the goals
so we use all the wrong analogies in
business we use War analogies it's a
launch it's a campaign you know we use
uh Sports analogies you know uh it's
it's Fourth and goal and like we've got
a you know and and they're all finite
constructions
um we need to start thinking of business
like a lifestyle
right think of it more like Health like
I want to be healthy what does it take
to be healthy well you have to exercise
you have to eat right you have to nurse
your personal relationships you have to
get enough sleep there's probably 30
other things you can't do all of these
things perfectly all the time it's a
striving well what you have to do well
in business you need good products you
need good service you need good
leadership
so you can't do all those things
perfectly all the time it's a striving
and you can absolutely have arbitrary
goals in that we love a metric human
beings love a metric so for example I
want to lose x amount of weight by X
date arbitrary number arbitrary date
which is largely how we pick financial
goals we're going to hit this goal by
this date
make it this number you know
and it's arbitrary
and that's fine
and so you go and you stand on the scale
every morning you're dueling all the
right things we love measuring we love
counting we love feeling the progress
and then you hit your goal and the right
day and the right time and you're
ecstatic but here's the thing you have
to keep exercising for the rest of your
life it doesn't end and it's the same
with business you hit your goal but the
whole thing called business and all that
striving and marketing and it it doesn't
end like you have to keep doing it but I
think it's more interesting when we miss
the goal
because if you're doing all this stuff
and you stand on the scale on that day
and you miss your goal you know what
happens you keep working out nothing
happens
right and what's more important is the
trend
because you are more healthy now you're
healthier now than you were when you
started you just happened to pick the
wrong date clearly you're going to hit
it in a month
and I think what we as companies need to
start doing is first of all
contextualizing the goal the reason we
need to hit this goal is because it
helps us build towards that bigger
Vision yeah and
when we hit it we look at the context do
we have bad leadership that just you
know at the last minute in the last
quarter had all these promotions so they
could hit their numbers but they're a
terrible leader building a terrible team
and this has been their year
but we bonus that person versus the
other team that's really well LED that's
doing everything right beautiful steady
growth line they just happen to miss the
number we give them nothing so we're
accidentally incentivizing the wrong
behaviors I think we need to start
looking at Trend data because that's
infinite mindedness and I think we need
to start contextualizing those goals if
they lack context if it's goal for the
point of goal you're in a finite game